هناك صور جديدة للأقمار الصناعية تُظهر
القافلة الروسية المتوقفة التي يبلغ طولها 40 ميلًا
بالقرب من كييف والتي كنا نتحدث عنها
الآن منذ أيام ، حيث تشتت إلى حد كبير
وأعادت نشر بعض الوحدات هناك
التي تم تغيير موقعها الآن في الغابات
والمناطق المحاطة بالأشجار ، فماذا يفعل؟  هذا يعني
دعنا نحضر
اللواء المتقاعد جيمس سبايدر ماركس في الجيش للحديث عن
هذا ، هل يمكنك أن ترينا ما تخبرنا به هذه الصور
وماذا تعني إلى
أين تتجه هذه الدبابات ، نعم أعتقد أن
هذه أخبار جيدة بصراحة
للأوكرانيين.  لقد حصلنا على تلك الصور
لتلك القافلة التي يبلغ طولها 40 ميلًا والتي
يتم تفريقها الآن مما يعني
أن الإمدادات لا تصل إلى حيث
يحتاجون إلى الذهاب وهناك تغيير في
التكتيكات وهم يبتعدون عن
شبكات الطرق لأنهم قلقون بشأن
صور كهذه و  أيضًا بعض
الاستهداف المحتمل ، لذا ما يمكنك رؤيته
في هذه الصورة هو أنهم لا يزالون على
شبكات الطرق ، ولكن عندما تنظر
هنا ، يمكنك رؤية المسارات التي تقع خارج
الطرق الرئيسية ثم تحديد  إذا كان
هنا أيضًا بريانا ، يمكنك أن ترى أين
يوجد عدد من الدبابات أو ناقلات
الجند المدرعة التي
تنطلق الآن من تلك الطرق الرئيسية
للحماية ،
وهذا يعني أنه يبدو كما لو كانوا قد ذهبوا
إلى حقل خلف منزل
بالتأكيد  إنهم يبحثون عن غطاء
ما يبحثون عنه تمامًا ،
هناك شيئان هناك دون
الدخول إلى الكثير من العناصر العسكرية ،
لكن هذا
إخفاء وإخفاء ، مما يعني أنني أريد أن أكون
تحت الأشجار وأريد أن أضع بجوار
المباني التي أريدها  لجعل الأمر صعبًا على
أي شخص أن يراني حقًا غطاء يمنحني
الحماية من إطلاق النار ، بمعنى آخر
، الحواجز الكبيرة والغطاء العلوي الذي من
شأنه أن يحمي حقًا من الرصاص
والصواريخ والصواريخ والمدفعية ،
لذلك قد يكون هذا مؤشرًا جيدًا
للأوكرانيين أنهم يشعرون بالضعف  ولكن
يمكن أن يكون أيضًا مؤشرًا على
أنهم يستعدون لشيء
ما بوضوح ، فإن ما يفعلونه هو أنهم شعروا
أنهم شعروا بالضعف الشديد
في الروس في  في طريق رئيسي للنهج ،
يمكن للعالم بأسره أن يرى
أنهم توقفوا عن العمل ، ولم يذهبوا إلى أي مكان
ولا يمكنك فعل أي شيء عندما
تصطف للتو ، تبدأ في تفريق
وحداتك الفردية مثل هذا يمكن
فجأة ضباط الصف
ويمكن للضباط المبتدئين
جمع قواتهم معًا والاستعداد للمهمة التالية والبدء في التحضير
لها ، حيث
تمر بوقت صعب للغاية عندما يكون لديك
هذا الصف من البط على الطريق ، لذا فإن
هذا يمنحهم فرصة
للاستعداد ، أرى ذلك.  بطريقتين ،
أحدهما يتطلع إلى حماية أنفسهم
للحد من مقدار الذكاء الذي
يمكن استخلاصه من عرض
المركبات هذا على طريق سريع رئيسي ، كما أنه
يمنحهم فرصة للاستعداد
للخطوة التالية